hey everybody and welcome to an
unforgettable wild ride with stevo this
week we have frankie muniz famously of
malcolm in the middle and if you google
frankie munez you will read that he
can't even remember being on malcolm in
the middle because of concussions or
mini strokes medical conditions and we
ask him about this he gets to the bottom
of this rumor for the very first time
publicly ever wow it's a big deal and
you know what else is a big deal
the holidays man and i want you to win
your white elephant gift giving award
with a gift that's gonna make people
laugh
and they're actually gonna use it what
gift is that well
it is
the lawnmower 4.0 from manscaped which
is responsible for the young and sexy
look i'm sporting right now man do i
love my manscaped grooming products keep
me looking young and fit and i better
look fit because i'm doing a photo shoot
for men's health in five days but
besides the point let's get you to win
that gift giving contest by stocking up
on manscape gear and getting a 20 off
plus free shipping bonus that's right if
you go to manscaped.como
it's 20 off your order plus free
shipping and dude i use it i love it
it's fun it's funny and you need to buy
this for your loved ones for the
holidays one more time manscaped.como
20 off your order plus free shipping now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen frankie muniz
what's up yeah dude man thank you for
doing this no thanks for having me out
this is cool and we've met scott
randolph and he's got the gorgeous paul
briskey what's up bro how's it going
great to meet you
we were talking about arizona real
estate before you got here yeah about
that dude how long have you been in
phoenix i've actually lived here for 13
years
right after malcolm ended i
i bailed and came here and
never looked back
um and then
it's true that you're a race car driver
yeah uh with 2005 i started but when i
was still doing malcolm i started racing
a little bit and then kind of went into
professionally after the show ended i
raced in former bmw moved up into champ
car champ car atlantic's had an indycar
ride for 2010 but i broke my back pins
in my hand
a whole bunch of
big injuries and just
by time i healed i started doing other
things and always thought i'd go back
racing and you know i guess there's
still time is it true that when you race
you actually like lose a lot of weight
during the race oh yeah i think you know
one thing people think with race car
drivers is oh i drive all the time i
drive down the highway like it's not
a sport it's not physical you're driving
a wheel car
you're pulling five g's in the corner
your heart rate never drops below 180
beats per minute the entire two hours
it's like sprinting uphill for two hours
so you'll lose seven eight pounds a race
easily
um how do you go do you go pee at all
you're just losing so much liquid that
you just sweat it all out there's times
where like before like right when the
race is about to start like again the
car i'm like oh my god the p and they
they tell you just pee in your suit and
there's two reasons a like you don't
have time to get out but b if you crash
with a full bladder you're gonna explode
your bladder yeah
so
just pee in your suit it's fine don't
hold it yeah don't have you ever peed in
your suit i peed in my suit but took
away you know at first i don't want a
room i gotta get out you know to me like
i gotta like if you win you're gonna
like hug people
but uh but no it's it's one of those
kind of as soon as the green flag goes
out
your brain like you kind of forget it
you know i mean for me at least yeah you
know yourself
that's crazy i don't know if you're like
going on going on stage or something
you're like i got a p but you go on
stage and i'll say you're like oh i
forgot right dude that's me you know i
have to pee before everything god steps
on stage and his heart rate never goes
under a hundred and eighty beats yeah
anyways eight pounds a week a race
and then i'm like like oh my god this is
not normal instead i'm checking steve's
heart rate it's like 51 52 i'm like
does that even happen dude
everybody's different man yeah so i
remember from uh you know like
when you were younger doing malcolm in
the middle like you were like the kid
with the obnoxiously flashy cars yeah
and uh
that was kind of your deal and and i
think at the time you were like maybe
like barely legal age to drive yeah and
you had these crazy cars and and i i got
a kick out of that man yeah and created
you getting ready to speak to today and
seeing that you're now 35 years old yeah
i know it's over it's everybody like
it's over i mean i just think of you as
like yeah because everybody does things
yeah you know
yeah so going back
cars were definitely my vice you know
what i mean like i've always liked cars
obviously i went into racing and all
that but like even before that i just
loved cool cars i love driving
um but yeah now
you know i look back and i think of my
life
20 years ago and i go
was that i really was that me like
that that was pretty cool you know what
i mean so right you know now i uh you
know i have an eight-month-old son and a
wife and i drive a mitsubishi
paul here was saying
that he read something or saw something
that uh that you have suffered a bunch
of concussions which make uh
make it difficult for you to remember
like the years of malcolm in the middle
yeah
you know it's it's an interesting
i i've
i've thought about it a lot like over my
years of like you know why do i have a
bad memory you know what i mean the only
logical thing i can say is yeah i've had
nine concussions you know what i mean
like i've and they're all from cars no
when i was a kid playing basketball and
getting tripped i played football you
know like pee wee football like just
doing okay life things sports and you
know uh there were some in in car caught
like racing accidents but you know for
the most part no like it's not just that
but and i i try i've gone to a lot of
doctors over it and uh looked into it
and
i don't know as weird as it sounds
i don't want to blame the concussions or
blame anything else i just think it's
the fact that i did so [ __ ] much
okay when in that time frame that of
course i can't remember all of it you
know what i mean okay
you know do you remember you have some
memory of memories you know like like
there's there's definitely things that
pop up and i go like whoa but a lot of
it
of my memories now are almost like i
can't distinguish if it was a dream or
if it was reality right you know what i
mean like thing places i went things
like you know people i hung out whatever
it was you know what i mean i heard
something also that did they do that i
heard something also that you've you've
had like these mini strokes throughout
your life yeah is that related to the
concussion is that a separate thing
this is why maybe without getting into
it like i i never trust doctors anymore
the rest of my life um i went for a long
time i was having these uh
these episodes uh
where
i'd have like numbness and i couldn't
really see like i lose peripheral vision
and all this stuff and everyone was
telling me like you're having tias
transient ischemic attacks or mini
strokes i'm like what like what are you
talking about like i'm healthy like i
don't do or you know i don't have any of
the the the signs of people who would
normally have those things so like it
didn't make sense so i went to a bunch
of doctors and nobody could really give
me like a straight up answer so i had
people kind of speculating and of course
like i said what they were speculating
and now it turns out literally after all
that and like if you search my name like
all it talks about is how like i have no
memory or i'm dying of strokes
and all this kind of stuff
and the reality is like i finally got
diagnosed with aura migraines
so just intense
intense migraines that literally like
those are the symptoms and it is similar
symptoms to transit ischemic attacks
okay now all this time like i've been
being told that and thinking that we're
realistically like i just had some
pretty intense migraines got you but the
story's out there is
like you searched my name it's basically
he's dying right
he doesn't know where he is
he doesn't even know that he was malcolm
i'm like yeah
that's the impression i got that was
kind of the headline i read like he
doesn't even know
and it's funny because like i i've never
talked about it i did dancing with the
stars
four years ago now wow we've had a lot
of guests that have done dancing i did
dancing with the stars did you have fun
did you enjoy it i did not enjoy it i
loved it
you know what i love
taking a humongous
healthy
complete [ __ ] and i also love a sponsor
that encourages me to use the word [ __ ]
and that sponsor ladies and gentlemen is
squatty potty
i am proud to tell you that i've been
using squatty potty for
at least seven years before i was
introduced to the company professionally
yeah dude i swear by it i'm loyal to it
and i don't i won't poop in any other
position what is this it's a little
stool that goes in front of your toilet
so you can elevate your legs while
you're taking a dump and that will allow
you to have a complete bowel movement
because you see the human body wasn't
designed to sit on a toilet i mean
cavemen they were crouching in the woods
man
pooping and they were in the right
position and people these days aren't
unless they're using squatty potty so
i'm telling you for your own bowel
health to avoid all kinds of
bad
health problems
use squatty potty and take a more
satisfying complete and healthy [ __ ]
yeah plus if you go to squattypotty.com
stevo you get 20 off your order and just
in time for the holidays to give people
another
funny
winning elephant man gift that they will
actually use i'm telling you i'm all
about squatty potty so go to
squattypotty.com
stevo
and uh get 20 off your order and hurry
up because
they're the best good people too now
let's talk dancing
i can't blame the show and and like
after my season i went back and you know
i was a friend of the show and i'd go to
like the following sequels and seasons
and sit in the audience and stuff it was
just like uncomfortable for me man i was
i was newly sober and i was like just
like in a really awkward phase of my
life and it's an awkward thing to do
yeah you know well how did you join the
show i did pretty good i made it to the
finale wow so that's top two top three
top three
and uh i
i was a nervous wreck every single time
i had to go out and say like i was a
disaster because like i'm a little
neurotic like i want to be
not perfect but like i want to do my
best you know what i mean and i put a
lot of pressure on myself but that's
like that competitive
like
sure nature in me that i just want to i
want to be the best i can be so like i
would i would be in rehearsal like 12
hours a day like longer than anybody i
think i broke the record for most
rehearsing in a season but that's just
the way 12 hours a day if not more geez
that was like in the studio like then i
go home and like practice too because
i'm just i'm i'm a
fool wow were you like that with like
rehearsing lines and stuff always and
[ __ ] like that that was always easy for
me like i would look at it once or twice
before i went to bed and like i'd wake
up in the morning and somehow i just
know it you know so that was never like
a thing but i'm not a dancer you know
right right at all
and you know they've been asking me to
do the show for like 12 years like all
seasons i was like no hell no i don't
dance like it's not my personality like
i'm right even though i'm in in uh the
entertainment business i'm pretty shy i
think you know what i mean like i'm not
like i don't want to be seen you know to
me i'm more like i'll be over here sure
give me my lines i'll say my lines and
i'll go back to my trailer you know what
i mean like i'm not
hollywood or whatever you want right but
i did it and i'll say the first
episode the first like time i went on
stage
it was one of the coolest feelings i've
ever felt like hearing like the crowd go
crazy like when i when i know i and i
killed it so i was really excited so i
enjoyed it but anyway i was bringing
that up because i was talking about
that's kind of where the story came from
of my memory
uh from their little story line on the
show yeah because they have they have
um an episode like most memorable year
and to be honest like i love dancing
with the stars and i don't want to like
say anything they'll make them hate me
but they kind of tell you what your most
memorable year is going to be you know
what i mean and they were like it's 2001
because it's when you were nominated for
an emmy and the golden globes and all
that kind of stuff and they're like we
want you to talk all about it and i go
i don't remember what i felt that like i
don't you know and so it was me kind of
blowing off the fact that like i can't
say that's my favorite year because like
i can't tell you what happened in 2001
you know what i mean like you would have
to tell me what happened in 2001 like
frankie muniz can't even remember but
they didn't they didn't really say it
just kind of like the storyline in my
episode then was like you know i as
cheesy as it is i said my most memorable
year is like is the present because i've
learned through all my past to live in
the moment like accept everything for
what it is whatever right and i brought
up like the fact that like i don't
i had to say like i don't really
remember
but i wasn't saying i don't remember
anything i was just saying
right if you told me what i ate for
breakfast the day that i went to the
when i was nominated for emmys i go i
have no idea right i mean like
that's so funny i was under the
impression like someone had to tell you
like no dude you were on this show
malcolm in the middle of the night and
you're like how you described it to me
that's how i always thought it was and
you'd be watching episodes
this is that's right this is the first
time that i've actually ever gotten to
clarify oh well great we're gonna cut
no no we'll we'll promote this dude this
is a big deal it's it's just funny
because like you know i have people
write me all the time like oh it's so
sad that you don't i'm like
that's why i don't
like hi frankie
how are you
right my wife he just met she
i am afraid
to forget memories now as you know what
i mean like because like or good moments
like i watched
so she
has journaled like our entire
relationship you know what i mean why
because she thinks you're gonna forget
it ask him
i might need it i might need it
eventually
but uh i uh
you know i i just like to be able to go
back because when i read it on paper it
brings me back to that to that moment
completely you know what i mean and even
now having a son like he's eight months
old then i go like how is he eight
months old you know because i i remember
him how he is right now it's not that i
don't remember but i see him right now i
can't remember
just like any other normal person
journals yeah
yeah cause i have a problem with my
memory too but like i also read that
like smart people do that because they
have so much bandwidth going in that
they don't they purposely just let it go
out because if they retain it all
they're gonna lose their [ __ ] mind i
think that is i mean i'm definitely
smart so
no i i think that's more of it to be
honest like is
especially if you think i started acting
when i was eight
malcolm when i was 12 to 20. you know
like i was literally every moment of my
life from when i started acting until i
stopped i had to be somewhere and had to
do something yeah you know what i mean
so there becomes a point i think where
you just kind of start
just in one ear out the other floating
but you just kind of you do what you got
to do when you go where you need to go
and and you do your best job but then
you forget it well it's crazy because
like you know i i i found i had this
problem and then i'd go to steven like
dude i can't remember it and steve can
remember the month in the year to a t
but like his third grade teacher said to
him line by line and i'm like what the
[ __ ] yeah your mother is crazy i
generally have a really good memory yeah
particularly for dates and stuff like
that however i totally relate to what
you were saying about you know so much
stuff happened like for example if
if i were to sit down and watch an
episode of my old show wild boys yes
which we taped all over the world from
2003 to 2005. yeah i
i'm sure that a bunch of the scenes that
were i have no recollection
i did that yeah i did that like i should
remember wait you you wouldn't
i would absolutely not like i would i
would i would feel like i was watching a
bunch of that stuff for the same time
and and it's specifically because what
frankie said just so much happened right
yeah so there was just so much going on
all the time so yeah but wow
i i got to watch i never watched malcolm
you know when it was on you just you
kind of film it but now with like the
streaming services like you can sit down
and and just kind of crank through and
my wife had never seen it so we watched
it a few years ago and i truly could
watch it as
like a fan
because i i really didn't know what was
going to happen to it
i could watch it as a fan because i'm
[ __ ] awesome yeah
i don't see it
but also because when you film i filmed
the parts i was in i don't really know
what else they found in the show what
did i mean like i don't know how that
turned out or that you wouldn't watch it
when it aired
no like a viewing party with your buds
oh no no
i was always kind of more like
embarrassed to like i don't know it just
kind of wow awkward i said 12 to 20. so
eight or nine years
it was seven seasons 151 episodes um
those years so so and that was like
network television when network
television was still like yeah yeah you
know it was pre
i mean i want to say pre-internet but
barely like you know youtube yeah there
was no youtube there was no social media
there was it was uh it was network tv or
basic cable yeah and that was it it was
it was crazy though because like you
know obviously as a as an actor or
anything that you do right you
you know i got the i remember
auditioning and i didn't want to go to
the audition because i was supposed to
film a pizza hut commercial that day and
i was like mom we cannot be late to the
pizza commercial she said we'll go early
we'll go early so she we we went in the
casting director wasn't even there she
walked in we're like can we just be seen
real fast i went in i was like
like i don't even care just say the
words i gotta go pizza hut you know what
i mean this is my big break
and um
and they call and they're like you're
malcolm so you get the pilot you film
the pilot you know and you think there's
what of 200 pilots a year
right six or seven get picked up and
then what they get picked up and only
two of those make it past episodes
and so i remember every step of the way
just being like
whoa this is happening and the first
time i was
we lived in new jersey and i uh i
auditioned for stuff in new york city we
lived like 10 miles from new york city
and we took the subway and there was
malcolm middle posters all over the
subway and someone like came up to me
and was like oh you're gonna be on that
show that's you and i was like that was
the coolest thing in the history of life
wow but then
you still don't think anyone's gonna
watch it like you don't know right i
don't feel like like i feel like now
people have an idea if something's gonna
be super successful well do you know
what channel was gonna be on it was on
fox it we knew it was gonna be it was
everybody's gonna watch that [ __ ] well i
don't i don't know you know and and the
first episode aired and 23 million
people tuned in oh [ __ ] and then they
re-aired it on wednesday and 28 million
people tuned in wow
and then we knew we were like oh wow
this is
this actually is going to be pretty good
how many people were watching jackass
like season one i mean dude there would
be like the most was like four million
on mtv well because it was cable too
like this was never like i didn't have
cable but like i would watch in the
middle you know yes network tv was a
much bigger deal than basic cable yeah
so your mom took you to auditions and
stuff was your mom like managing your
career and stuff i i
yeah i don't know if she ever fully
took on that
label or that role but like it was you
know i when i was a kid i'd go from
football practice to a baseball game to
you know auditions to tap and jazz
whatever it was you know to me so she
just kind of made sure i got where i
needed to go and then it took over my
life you know what i mean like and it
took over her life too you know what i
mean so i'm super grateful
for her to think now of like
wow
i could have had a parent that was like
no we're not going you know anything
right
it's exhausting to do all that stuff
yeah and uh so
yeah and so you had earned i'm guessing
a whopping amount of money but by the
time you turned 18
and uh
does that mean that um
like
aaron carter was telling us that they've
just like established some law that
parents have to like save
like 15 percent
yeah the coogan law so i automatically
like a check from fox doesn't go to me
whatever the percentage is i forget what
it is
goes to a trust like it goes into like
an account that you can't touch until
18. because there's been supposedly in
the past so many kid actors that they
work and the parents spend all the money
right you know and so at least they
would have that maybe it's 15 or 20
percent it's unbelievable
they passed a lot to say that parents
can only blow eighty-five percent
yeah
so but were your parents pretty like
good with the money and stuff and like i
mean we hired you know business managers
like that you know right away um
uh
yes
i'm very fortunate in that sense like my
mom never wanted to spend any money like
you know we were always very
i i call the
frugal you know what i mean like outside
of the cars outside of the car well that
was like i said it was my one right you
know thing where i go oh maybe i
shouldn't have done that you know what i
mean but uh
uh but no pretty i mean you could have
done a lot worse though because i also
read maybe this isn't true because i
read a lot but like uh you never really
got into drugs or drinking or anything
like that i've never
drank i've never done anything uh at all
so you could have blown a lot there and
i didn't like that crazy 16 years old
going to the playboy mansion every night
so okay
so that's what i was going to say like
so life did get kind of crazy like you
were like a kid celebrity you weren't
just like i go to work then i go home
and i'm just a normal kid you were like
i mean a celebrity i i didn't
i never enjoyed going out you know to me
i think that's part of it like i went
out like i'd go out every once in a
while and i just would get home at 2 30
in the morning and be like why that was
so stupid you know what i mean
so i it wasn't my thing um but no but i
definitely i have stories for sure you
know what i mean yeah crazy life
experiences that yeah i mean what was
the playboy mansion like for a 15 year
old
what's being at the playboy mansion like
for a 15 year old kid can we say
boy
i mean dude
hard as a rock and you know what makes
me extra hard as a rock taking blue chew
tablets baby if you haven't tried them
let me tell you they are an unbelievable
amount of fun plus it's very easy to get
them because you don't have to go to an
awkward uncomfortable in-person doctor
appointment to get your prescription you
just go to bluechew.com
and consult with one of their medical
providers and boom it's so fast and easy
and next thing you know you have an
entire month's supply of blue chew
tablets which have the same active
ingredient as both viagra and cialis
except they're chewable and cost only a
fraction of the price but get this if
you use the promo code stevo
bluechew.com
you get that entire month's supply of
bleacher tablets
absolutely for free
all you gotta pay is five bucks for
shipping so
how about getting hard as a rock baby by
going to bluetooth.com using the promo
code stevo and getting a whole month's
supply absolutely for free just pay five
bucks for shipping and your boner can
thank me later yeah dude now let's see
what the playboy mansion was like for
frankie muniz
heaven
did you lose your virginity at the
playboy
not at the playboy mansion but
that he remembers yeah
so did you uh like
get invested in like real estate and
stuff like i just think [ __ ] man if if i
had like
been better with investments if i'd
gotten like real estate like early on or
like whatever like
i did i i
unknowingly made choices not unknowingly
like just thought it was like on a whim
kind of things that worked out really
well you know what i mean i was never
the type of person where i was like oh i
got to think strategically it was more
like oh this seems cool and like i'd buy
a house or like you know
i had a bunch of houses at one time and
the market went crazy so i made a ton of
money on them you know what i mean but
it was never like uh you know people i i
own some parking lots in downtown l.a
wow which is nice
then you you know you know downtown l.a
from i don't know 2002 there was really
nothing there and now it became like a
pretty trendy there's so much down there
so i did really well there so stuff like
that still have them no i
sold them in 2006. i wish i had them now
because then they'd be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars was like
an apartment building built there yeah
yeah yeah things was a pretty good time
to get out
yes well yes in the sense that right
before the big
housing crisis that we were talking
about if you still had it now now like
now it's right things are playing like
the monthly income from that is [ __ ]
crazy right you know you have like one
or two employees who take money all day
from cars you know what i mean right
there's no overhead everyone's while
they paint the lines right right yeah no
overhead yeah
where what streets were your parking
lots we were all around staples center
um all around so you get a lot yeah
jesus dude
way to go how do you think to get in the
parking lots who tells you that
i just i i'm a weird person in the sense
that like when i was a kid i wanted to
be like a garbage man or want to be a
trained conductor and i always like i
want to own storage facilities the
stupid like that's just where my brain
goes and that was one of those where i
was like
why don't we buy this because
even if you're only charge i would go
like even if you're only charging five
dollars a car which people down here are
charging twenty dollars to park you know
what i mean we could be the cheap block
you know what i mean yeah and
you're gonna have people all day coming
through
and
i don't know i just like saying
i have to say that i'm absolutely
fascinated by this conversation man i
just feel compelled to thank you again
one more time for doing this dude
you don't you don't do
like a great deal of
interviews
not these days no um i moved here in
2008 not to hide not to but like i
wanted to focus on other things you know
what i mean i did that and now i'm at a
you know
interesting time in my life i feel like
where i've i've grown a lot
just but by having stepped away you know
what i mean sure right and i'm
i don't know happy with myself not that
i wasn't you know what i mean like i
just kind of like where i'm at in my
life and
what's it what's the day in the life
like for you you wake up you check your
massive portfolio
you have coffee
you jump into a bugatti and race a few
laps no no i you know it's funny because
the
last three or four years with my wife
we've had just
the most kind of stressful crazy things
happen to us
um i was telling you that my my cat we
had a brownstone down here in downtown
phoenix a five-story brownstone my cat
turned on the faucet on the top floor
when we were gone for three days and a
million gallons of water destroyed our
brown stone everything everything i own
every piece of art every picture
every piece of furniture wow so like
that took two years to rebuild we
finally got it done and we realized like
we had like ptsd from it and built all
that so
stuff like that that like takes over
your life because like then you're yeah
we actually bought a bus and we toured
around a little bit just while the house
was being rebuilt and just kind of stuff
like that but but every day people go oh
what are you what are you up to
and i don't know what to say
but i'm so [ __ ] busy all the time and
it
it does bother me because i'm like i
should be people think i probably have
like the easiest life ever because i
don't have a nine to five i don't really
you know what i mean but like we're
always just busy with i'm involved in
kind of so many different little
businesses and things here and there
that like they take up all my time
but i am getting back
no one knows this either i shouldn't i'm
not technically supposed to announce it
yet but i am going back racing next year
full time um for the first time in 12
years and just signed a big deal and uh
excited yeah excited to do that yeah
well do you not want to get into it that
we don't have to i do not i don't want
to i just you can't yeah because i'm you
know
yeah should we cut that out or that just
at least that little bit is all right
maybe we'll announce before yeah okay
it's we're super really close to yeah
making the big announcement and is it
what like uh
nascar formula one or just okay yeah
so something like that one of those it's
something i haven't raced before but
very big got it wow dude wow do you have
to train for that i have been i've been
on the road every day for the last
basically three months in a car
testing
around the streets no like tracks all
over um
mostly in southern california um
like havasu tucson kind of close to here
but just to get as much experience as
possible because it's even though i
raced before it's like equivalent to
saying i'm uh a olympic swimmer and an
olympic diver you know what i mean they
both involve water but they're
completely two different sports that's
kind of what i uh relate the two
different forms of racing today wow epic
when um
so i also saw the thing that was like
that you know after malcolm you're dying
after malcolm you were trying to get
into like more serious roles and it just
didn't like click yeah for you
you know it's funny i've done some
serious roles and i enjoy them the most
of anything i've ever done
um it was also more
when malcolm ended i started i got
signed to bmw to race cars and i said to
my agent's manager i said go look
this is what i want to do you know what
i mean
i'm not trying to just do it as a hobby
like i want to be the best i can be and
like anything if you want to do
something the best you've got to put in
the time you need to get in the work you
know so i didn't think that it was
humanly possible to continue acting or
continuing the entertainment business
while doing the racing thing
so that's one thing like i'm so happy
sorry i'm so happy i went racing i love
every aspect of it now it's becoming a
part of my life again yeah and i think
in the in the biggest way it could but
i look back and i go
did i make a mistake leaving in the
height of my career like when i had
hundreds of offers i could have kept
going non-stop and i said no i don't i
don't want to where now i look back and
not that like i i
actively am pursuing trying to be an
actor but i go i wonder what my life
would have been if i stayed in that same
sense i look back and i go
thank goodness i left because i
appreciate life in general more because
i've started taking more in and i look
back at the success i had and i go
that was really cool you know what i'm
happy thank god
i i think that you made the healthier
move definitely and i don't think i ever
would have been able to do that yeah i
think that i'm like just so
chronically
like attention-seeking
yeah and external validation oriented
that i would never be able to do that i
i feel like
and i i don't want you or anyone to take
this the wrong way i'm so much of a
happier person oh i bet having stepped
away not like being out of the line none
of that like just
i don't know like
i don't know how to it's just a weird
it's a weird i've never been happier
like in my life like for some living in
arizona like something about arizona was
like i was like
content well
it's funny that
it's funny that you say that because
like when i moved here i realized as
cheesy as this sound i started looking
up for the first time like looking the
clouds the weather the mountains the
long distance yeah rather than like i
don't know in l.a i just kind of like
kept my head down like like literally
kept my head down all the time a lot of
sharks in l.a
i think people people want something
from you everywhere you go in l.a yeah
so maybe you're just kind of like
shrieking i don't know yeah i don't i
don't know i just i feel like this is
where i'm supposed to be i was told by
uh
i went to new orleans when i was like 11
and got my palm read
and the
the palm reader like told me all this
stuff and they go do you want to know
who you were in your past life i was
like sure
and he goes you were a judge
defending the native americans in the
southwest and he goes that's why you're
drawn to the southwest at the time i've
never been west of the mississippi river
i'm from new jersey you know what i mean
like the southwest the minute i came
here i was like this is where i'm
supposed to be you know what i mean it's
weird so i don't fully believe in that
stuff but at the same time i go like i
think he was onto something yeah
damn what was it like for you watching
brian cranston's like resurgence with
you know you know
not
like
no lie he's the greatest human being
alive
like as an actor as a person like he'd
show up every single day and you know
when you do something every day you kind
of like you can get annoyed with
already done
never he was so happy like to be there
and so great to the crew and so great to
everyone so in my head he's
like my idol because i'd like people to
say that same thing about me but
no one deserves it more never mind the
fact that he's an incredible actor i
mean he's done now so many different
things and
i don't i don't
think anyone can beat him you keep in
touch with him still you know it's funny
i don't know you know people you're on
your shows with or whatever like
you always go oh we're going to stay
best friends forever right everyone kind
of says that like summer camp you go to
summer camp we're going gonna write each
other every single day we're gonna be
best friends and then you go home and
everyone kind of starts living their
life and
you just kind of forget brian reaches
out to me
every two weeks and he has for
15 years wow
like literally reaches out to just
checking on you hope you're well what
are you up to like he's literally
hollywood god
and he's he calls me he's [ __ ]
heisenberg you know he's the best i'm a
piece of [ __ ]
me too dude every time i see a friend
i'm like dude why don't i call you like
i'm so sorry i've never reached out to
anybody right yeah i mean here's the
thing too that i'll i'll have a little
thought to myself like oh you know like
i should reach out to somebody just
getting stoked you know man
make me feel good if i like and i have
that thought and then it just
flutters away and i don't do anything
and then you check your social media how
many likes you got in the last place
it's like well i tried like
now i'm never gonna try for two years
yeah
speaking of uh living in arizona are we
making it official
we're gonna lose i'm moving to tucson in
like june yeah yeah what's bringing you
there
my girlfriend lived there for a long
time beyonce
she's getting it she's getting ready my
fiance lived there for a long time uh
and she moved out to la like to be with
me and we're just ready for a change and
you know i got it's like you you know
like i'm mad you don't know
but um i don't know just time for change
and like buy a house and
kick it a little bit i mean you're
probably like one of the top five
youtube editors
living right because that are well
didn't that article come out of you guys
during the pandemic where you guys were
like top five youtube channels yeah like
what to watch during the pandemic and
they were like dude stevo's youtube
channel is [ __ ] top-notch editing and
it's all i am
so okay so you know maybe i'll find a
way to stay involved i'd like to find a
way to stay involved plus now i've been
opening for steve on these shows yeah
which is it these are my openers now
he's touring the enticing to keep
touring yeah
i'd be such a fool to pass that up so
we'll see but i i i am very likely
moving to tucson
yeah i'm glad because we
steve dropped the news on the last
podcast at the very end people were like
wait what you're leaving on the
yeah the outro i was just trying to like
be decisive you know so i was like i'm
leaving in february but but now it's
different
yeah and what do you think the real
estate market is doing in arizona do you
think it's gonna go down soon or you
think it's gonna go up what advice do
you have i'll say this two years ago
it's kind of the same
throughout a lot of the country now two
years ago pre-pandemic
the houses you could have bought will
now cost you double here like it's it's
crazy like it's to me it's stupid but
i don't know everyone has a lot of money
supposedly so
but i don't know that much i think
arizona might
fare better than other places
because
this is a place a lot of people are
moving to you know what i mean a lot of
people are leaving
you know the las the new yorks you know
the kind of bigger cities they want
still a big city but more space or more
spread out um right now we're
we've been open for a year and a half
too yeah so i think that brought a lot
of people here um where
other states had like super lockdown you
know so i think that's part of it
so i still see
because covet is still a thing and still
you know
i think gonna shut down some places
again do you think so
i mean you're i think didn't it
didn't yeah we didn't santa clara was
some county in california just said you
can't even be in your house without a
mask on they said yesterday yeah if
you're not allowed to go anywhere
without a mask not even in your house is
what they literally said yesterday wow
that's a little much it's so funny like
traveling through different state to
state like the difference
they are on laws and some places like
they're checking the vaccine cards the
door other places are like
arkansas nobody gave a [ __ ] about it
yeah yeah i was surprised in denver we
were walking into stores
yeah yeah
but they were checking vax cards at the
venue yeah i don't know it's interesting
i don't know i i don't know if that in
my head i think because they're
like over a million people moved here in
the last year and a half to phoenix
phoenix scottsdale like like literally
the population went from two million to
like three five you know like it's it's
growing insane
and that's the only logic to me i don't
know and the weather's good i mean
summers are hot but the rest of the
summer is just good garlic but every but
the nine months out of the year the
weather is the best weather in the world
yeah i would say it cools down at night
which i always like the summer you want
to probably have a
summer house
yeah do you have that or you'd stay here
for the cemetery we stay here i mean i
i don't mind the heat granted if i was
like a a roofer
or a construction worker i'd probably
think differently but you know you go
from your air-conditioned house into an
air-conditioned garage into your
air-conditioned car sure and you park
and there's misters that missed you into
the air-conditioned building you're
going right it's like it's made for the
heat it's also super dry i lived in new
orleans and you know even on the east
coast where like it's 85 but it's 100
humidity like to me that's way more
uncomfortable than 120 here yeah in my
head for sure it's like in the driver's
seat of a of a car like on a race you
just dripping sweat
um
do you yourself have siblings
i have a sister okay um she's a year and
a half older she lives in atlanta um
yeah
she's the reason i got into acting to be
honest because she wanted to be an
actress i was kind of like the kid who
just did everything
and she did like a summer arts like
little theater camp and they put on
joseph and the amazing technicolor
dreamcoat at the end of the summer or
whatever and i thought it was pretty
cool so she was going to be auditioning
for another play
and we were jumping on the trampoline
and she's like you should audition
she picked me a song she picked me let's
go fly a kite for mary poppins and i
went in and i sang it and it was for a
christmas carol and i got the part of
tiny tim
an agent saw me literally at the first
rehearsal signed me and from that day
until i left acting when i was 20 i
never stopped wow so like it was like i
said it truly was a thing that just took
over you know what i mean for my family
yeah you were just riding like a wave
yeah
where were we going do you keep in touch
with any other childhood actors
no it's like a small crew of you guys
yeah most of them are pretty weird um
bud bundy
are you guys about the same age no he's
a little older he's more like hillary
duff amanda bynes yeah yeah or his okay
peers yeah he uh
he did really well with uh you know
saving his money and being being wise
with it like he's like
insanely wealthy i think cool
yeah yeah no i mean i to be honest i
honestly can say
that i'm
a pretty bad friend
seriously like i'm you know i have so
many amazing people in my life that like
i want to be great friends with but
i
i don't know i i never kind of
i'm a very tight circle kind of people
yeah yeah you know i've got people i've
got a small number of people who are
very close to me and uh
and and i pride myself on having really
like they're close quality people around
me like uh
but yeah outside of that super inner
circle damn i'm a piece of [ __ ]
well i just like i'm really bad at
communication sure like i i actually i
hate
texting i'm old school like i'd like to
actually i'll talk to you on the phone
all day you know what i mean i just so
like i get a text message and i go i'll
respond later but then it's not new
anymore and it just keeps going down and
then i realized like a month later that
i did it right back you know what i mean
so like that's what i mean like i'm just
a bad friend because like and then
you're like about to text that person
then you see that message they sent you
like a month like yeah oh [ __ ] i'm just
seeing this now yeah sorry
also can you help me move like whatever
you're saying
i've had to say that so so many times
that like i can't use it anymore i don't
know why my phone didn't send it until
right right like how am i now just
seeing this i have no idea but there's a
certain type of person who doesn't give
a [ __ ] about texting
and there there's a certain type of
person who gets really butt hurt by that
yeah scott hates scott will text me like
if i'm not at work i just don't usually
respond to text my cheeks
yeah well come to come to find out
you're completely checked out when you
get out of work
i know you had a secret [ __ ] micro
dosing problem
i'm like oh well that makes sense
because like you just
i don't know a secret micro dosing
problem
i just like microsoft you know
no but i'm like well that makes sense
why you wouldn't reach because like
somebody you know you know you take
somebody and have a lot of peyote or
something that's why he's moving here
yeah i'm going there for the ostriches
and the peyote yeah for sure have you
been to that ostrich farm down in tucson
no i've always wanted to go have you
been no didn't you ride some ostriches
we rode ostriches in south africa i
think it was and uh i feel awful about
that today
i'm sorry
why because you felt bad for the ocean
i'd think that it was
it wasn't the kindest treatment of an
ostrich yeah i don't think they'd be too
stoked we can cut that out too
i i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna like
hide from my past um
okay speaking of hiding from your past
has anyone approached you about like a
malcolm in the middle reunion or like
agent cody banks three or anything like
that to be honest both
um and they were actually kind of real
like five years ago
pre anything making a
re-emergence you know now i feel like
every show has come back where like
people don't really care about shows
coming back right um we were talking
about it brian was leading it because he
wants to do it again and
um
we got everyone on board
except for one person but
they i don't they want to make it a
movie and i don't fully understand it
but i'd be thrilled you know what i mean
because it'd be cool to kind of see
where malcolm and his family are
20 years later whatever it is um but i
don't know what's happened with that i
know brian's been writing a script and
stuff like that so we'll see what
happens there but then agent cody banks
mgm has maybe i'm not allowed to say
this i don't know but i'm saying anyway
mgm has two really cool ideas for agent
cody banks
one is like a
bojack horseman
type
cartoon of agent cody banks like what
happens when you're watching when you've
saved the world as a kid like and you
can't better than what i mean like and
just down on it like you know oh we can
call james bond uh he's busy i guess
call cody bank you know he's the last
resort you know that dad you know now i
think it'd be hilarious really yeah
agent cody banks if you guys don't know
it was like a teenage special agent
movies that i think i watched in my 30s
okay
i'm down for that [ __ ] yeah but that's
funny yeah the cool thing now is like
you know the kids who watched it in 2003
are
25 30 years old you know who who would
be into that type of thing right so uh
they've they've come to me with that
which like i said
maybe maybe me bringing it up will light
the fire yeah i think it'd be a really
fun idea i think it's hilarious and then
they have another idea for it's still
being like a kids thing where i'm like
cody banks
teaching the new crop of uh teenage
spies what was the one that's uh in the
taylor shop and it's like oh uh uh
kingsman the kings are now those movies
are really cool yeah so you would be
like a kingsman type like
training train like the young yeah you
like the kingsman
i mean we went and watched it i really
like those i love it i like all those
kind of movies i think movies in general
just like i can only suspend so much
disbelief you know like before i start
thinking okay this is just i'm not
usually into like the big crazy action
movies like i i mean to be honest i've
never seen any of the marvel movies i
can't i can't get through marvel but
like kingsman i i really really enjoyed
that's cool because i don't know
just dude i love that man and uh
like i'm rooting for you to pull that
stuff off man that's killer
yeah sounds hilarious you could be going
into an exciting time to getting back in
the race car getting back in front of
the camera yeah it is it's it's a it's
weird you know because
i don't know where i'll be in six months
you know well i know i'm gonna be racing
now but you know like normally in my
life i go i i have no idea where i'm
gonna be
but
what we do have coming up
is the most that i've
had coming up so the potential is
the potential is the biggest says it's
ever been so you're about to lose your
memory again
i can't yeah um are you still drumming
no you know i
it's so funny that you ask i haven't
touched a drumstick since my last show
with my band at the university of
wyoming on february 13 2013. there's a
memory it's a memory february 13th 2013.
wow
so eight years i won't touch a drumstick
and in my head i go we were on tour with
ed sheeran like opening up arenas wow i
mean like you know playing in front of
arenas i go i can't go from like playing
in front of arena full of people to
playing in my bedroom by myself you know
what i mean like i'm not in a band i
don't
i do miss my band like i loved the band
and the music and like the camaraderie
of the guys
but at the same time like
i know that
that is not some like a lifestyle that
not that the lifestyle was bad but like
i can't be on the road sure
that much we in 2013 we are 24
no i'm sorry february 13 2014 2013 we
played 300 shows so we were literally on
the road the entire year tour bus
no like 15 passenger van that i was
driving with the trailer sleeping on
floors like we did it like that way
roughly what i mean
from arena to arena like that
[Music]
what do you get paid as an opening knack
for ed sheeran it depended like if we
were playing at like like universities
or colleges like
7 500 to 12 000. split between you guys
split between us drop you know but most
the shows we'd get
hundred two thousand dollar guarantees
which like
it it works you know what i mean like we
we made money as a band which is pretty
rare but you also get a band 10x that on
your parking lots that you own yeah yeah
i i was telling you how i'm frugal
like i'm the one they'd be like let's
get hotels and i'd be like
look we can't we can right there's six
guys we can get two rooms three room
whatever it is but times that by
a hundred days you know what i mean at
the end of that that would be an extra
fifty sixty thousand dollars in in our
pockets you know what i mean and they
worked normal day jobs you know what i
mean that's a big amount of money so i
can always kind of convince them to like
not because i think a lot of people like
bands they get deals or they get on tour
and they they try to do a big they get a
big tour bus or whatever it may be and
they're like wait we had this expense it
was cool and all but i would have rather
had the money when i came home right you
know what i mean and steve's like i i
really like the tour bus
i've done i've done the tour bus thing
too and it's amazing to be driven and
sure sleep and you know show up and be
yeah where you're at dude it's awesome
but we weren't at that level you know
what i mean like you know we weren't at
i think it would have been silly for us
to do it at the level we were at yeah
yeah someone told me one i used to tour
in bands too i was a drummer also
and somebody told me like it's not what
you earn on tour it's what you save yeah
that's what matters like if you're
trying to like get like four beers and a
nice dinner every night like you're
gonna go home with nothing you know well
we realized we could play you know
hundreds of shows and we knew someone in
every city
that would be like come stay at our
house we got extra bedrooms so you owned
a parking lot that you could park yeah
yeah
you know what i was saying this like it
was like cool we knew we knew where we
were going it was it was easy to to
you know for me as i like managed the
band too so like being the the neurotic
kind of planner and advancer and stuff
like that had it all squared away and
we did pretty good
um are you active on social media
i'm on social media i'm not the most
active i should be more
i just
my the last image that ever comes to my
mind is to like take out my phone and
take a picture you know what i mean so
like if it's not my wife
taking a photo you know what i mean or
my wife doing it
right i've done some like even in the
last couple months like some really
really cool stuff
and i'm like i don't have any pictures
to share you know what i mean i just
don't i just don't do it i've never went
back and looked at a photo that i've
taken anywhere ever unless i'm like
bored on the plane just like [ __ ] but
yeah i don't get the concept of like
you know everybody's like dude the
samsung galaxy has the best [ __ ]
phone for photo taking it's like i'm not
a photographer i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't i i like having
you know as like a memory thing but my
wife is so good at it that i don't have
to think about it yeah i mean she takes
great photos and of the baby and how
long you guys been together uh six years
now
married for two and a half how'd you
guys miss
uh
i
she was a professional golfer
and i i was trying to be a golfer that
was another and you hired her no i met
her at a golf tournament uh at like a
like a like an event like a dinner
and as cheesy as it is it was literally
like
the minute i saw her like we locked eyes
and it was
on like we were what was your pick-up
line
to be honest
she would tell the story she would tell
the story different because i saw her at
this dinner and i was like i've got it
like i'm just not the person to ever
approach someone would be like hey you
know like i'm frankie like i don't know
like what do you do so i was like if i
maybe if i'm around her
someone will introduce i don't know
she's like i kind of like followed her
around a little bit like creepily yeah
and sure enough her friend who she was
with was like hey do you remember me
i met you a few years ago and
i didn't but i was like yeah
and she she introduced me to her friend
and like we just sat there and chatted
for like five hours and
and uh yeah
the rest is history oh wow cool
that's that big deal story ah it's
beautiful it's beautiful
i i was about to ask do you have
anything that anything else to promote
that you're not supposed to promote
um
i'm gonna be on the surreal life uh
seriously on vh1 uh starting in january
i think it's going to be there
they're bringing that back we brought it
back yeah so
they put us in a this 30 000 square foot
house in mexico city a few months ago oh
you already filmed it you already filmed
it um and i'll say this
i was the nice person that everybody
liked and i got punched twice
so i have no idea
what they're gonna show because the
producers kept having to come in and be
like this is not what we wanted the show
to be we wanted it to be like fun and
light not like the kind of the old real
life it was more train wrecking they
wanted to be more like
uh us just doing this really cool stuff
and uh
it was wow it was rough can you say who
the rest of the cast is
yeah i think it's come out um it's
dennis rodman amazing uh
uh tamar braxton
um she was she's like tony brown tony
braxton's sister but tamar she was a
host of like the talk or the
one of those uh she had her own reality
show um she won celebrity big brother uh
manny mua the youtube yeah yeah makeup
artist who
to be honest
if he wasn't there him and kim coles kim
coles was on living single and in living
color back in the 90s
you'd rec you definitely would no yeah
if if they weren't there
there would have been a homicide
us three we call ourselves s3 the sober
three because we're the only ones who
weren't
going crazy
but if they weren't there there's no way
we would have all made it through wow
so dennis rodman wasn't sober the whole
time
he's not part of the s3
uh he's the leader this is the s3
this kid august alcina he um
is a r b singer okay he's
i don't want
i don't care if he likes me or not he
wasn't the greatest person but maybe i
shouldn't say that but he was the one
who like had an affair with jada pickett
smith yeah and will like the will i feel
like she's had an affair with everybody
yeah i mean even me
right now
um no uh
but yeah it was just it was an
interesting group
and i'm really curious to see what it
what they make it look like you sold me
dude i'm gonna check it out it wasn't it
was gnarly wow
unbelievable and and uh presumably vh1
will have some streaming platform but
that would be a paramount plus yeah
probably yeah yeah yeah
that's probably their motivation for for
doing it to draw more subscribers to
paramount plus
yeah
i'm glad i asked that dude no [ __ ] yeah
i don't it's weird because i don't know
what the show is going to be meaning
like you know because
they even they have cameras in the
bathrooms they have cameras
there's not a moment that's not filmed
and you go
i don't know how they can't show some of
this stuff but they're so i don't know
if like me being like oh it's going to
be crazy and they're like they cut all
the crazy out somehow
i have no idea so i don't know how much
i want to talk [ __ ] on people okay
because there were people i definitely
headed in that house wow but but for all
we know you might end up looking like a
dick on the show if they kind of right i
can't see that happening okay okay other
than in the last interview i i unleashed
on everybody because i was like i don't
want to protect these people anymore
they don't deserve protecting
very juicy stuff dude do you know when
that comes out i think they're saying
sometime in january i'm not entirely
sure wow
[ __ ] fascinating dude
i've really really enjoyed talking to
you that's really cool it's been fun
yeah man do we do we have any other
questions i feel like
i got to go set up the venue tonight i
genuinely feel like i want to be
protected with this i feel like this has
been so
fascinating entertaining the whole time
i want to like wrap it up just
mess it up yeah i really think it's been
that that [ __ ] fantastic dude dude i
mean i had questions in my head i i set
them all man
and then
paul brisk is absolutely uh
you know in in your uh
super die hard fan club yeah for sure
i mean i didn't have cable so like fox
was like my thing and i'm the middle of
three boys
like like i i was malcolm in the middle
like in my head you know so like my
mom's loud my dad's quiet like it was
he's dying to live in arizona
he's following you wherever you go he's
getting into race cars
so let's go home
this was cool man it was really cool to
meet you and get to talk to you man yeah
brother man thank you so much thank you
yeah that was great
how about that episode folks was that
epic or what plus it was brought to you
by pube shavers [ __ ] stools and boner
tablets and i could not be more proud of
that fact so hurry up and get some
holiday shopping done folks again it's
manscaped.com
stevo squattypotty.como
and
bluechu.com with the promo stevo
yeah dude plus come see me on the bucket
list tour if you live in america it's a
pretty strong chance i'm coming your way
whoa